[Музика]
так добре, хлопці, я радий знову бачити вас
у нашому класі,
як ви сьогодні, сподіваюся, у вас все добре, і
знову з нами містер Пол, привіт,
як у вас справи, хлопці,
ми  дуже раді отримати всі
відгуки про всі наші уроки,
і ми дуже раді читати ваші
відповіді та відповідати на них якомога більше
електронною поштою або в Instagram,
дякую за домашнє завдання, це
справді чудова робота,
ну, Павло, що ми збираємося  щоб поговорити
сьогодні про,
я думаю, ми будемо говорити про
дуже важливу тему, близьку моєму серцю,
огр,
справді добре, звичайно, ми будемо
говорити про Великобританію,
але саме ми будемо говорити про
шкільні іспити та освітню систему
тож подивіться, будь ласка, у нас є
кілька
питань тип університету gcs
є Paul що це gcses
так, це загальний атестат про
середню освіту огре
загальний атестат про середню
освіту
добре початкова
школа ступінь середня школа a рівні
знову що таке  Рівень a рівні - це
найвища
шкільна кваліфікація за останні два
роки навчання,
і це дає вам доступ до
університету,
тому і ігрова група, я думаю, що ці
речі розташовані не в хронологічному порядку,
ні, вони не в правильному порядку, тому
хлопці, як ви думаєте, що має бути
першим, що є першим,
де діти починають освіту,
звісно, це не університетське пр
во, Пол ні,
ні, не університетська йога, але якщо це
івень, означає, що першим правим мо
е бути, але також можна  будьте найкращими, якщо
ви
зірковий учень, я бачу,
тому я вважаю, що нам слід почати з ігрової
групи,
я думаю, що всі маленькі діти люблять
грати, тому
ігрові групи, які вікові групи для
ігрових
груп, можливо, дуже маленькі  три-п'ять,
добре, тож ігрова група для дітей від
трьох до п'яти, добре, так і наступна,
тож, я думаю, що це має піти в
початкову школу,
так, так що наступна
група - початкова група, і знову яка
вікова група,
це п'ять до  одинадцять п'ять до  одинадцять
добре ви закінчуєте початкову школу, коли
вам 11
так, ми дуже важко працюємо у Великобританії,
тож ви маєте на увазі
не чотири роки, а п'ять років так,
хлопці, чи можете ви уявити, що ви
залишите початкову школу у віці 11 років.
це означає, що після  в п'ятому
класі в україні все по-іншому добре, тож
тоді, я думаю, середня школа так
середня школа
добре, так що середня школа, і вікова
група цієї
школи буде від 11 до 18,
але ви можете залишити школу в 16
у Великобританії,
але більшість людей залишаються  і зробіть рівень
до 18.
добре, як можна покинути школу
до рівня a, тому що рівні
вони насправді для вступу до
університету, вони дають вам
доступ до хорошого університету, тому
деякі люди
в 16 вирішують закінчити школу і не йти
до  університет
і, можливо, маю кар'єру, роботу
чи роботу, яка не вимагає
університетського ступеня,
я бачу, що все добре, тому після
середньої школи
мені потрібно мати
право GCES так загальний атестат про
середню освіту
Так чи це такі тести, це
обов'язкові тести,
ви не можете стати студентом рівня A,
поки не закінчите gcses, добре,
тому я повинен скласти дев'ять тестів
дев'ять тестів чотири обов'язкові п'ять
ви вибираєте, тому чотири обов'язкові,
а потім п'ять необов'язкові  ну
дев’ять іспитів – це вже занадто,
а потім настає рівень
і лише три предмети так,
коли ми стаємо старшими у Великобританії, ми, як правило
, спеціалізуємось на предметах,
ага, так що після дев’яти іспитів
я повинен скласти три іспити правильно,
три рівня  іспити я бачу, тому
бата
ходить в україну, у нас тут більше предметів
і ще більше предметів на цьому рівні
, це цікаво,
добре, а після рівня ви мені сказали,
що я можу вступити до університету,
так, ви можете вступити в університет і
що мені робити  добре потрапив до університету,
якщо ти залишишся в університеті три-
чотири роки, у тебе буде ступінь бакалавра,
тож останній етап -
це ступінь бакалавра, а потім можна стати магістрам,
так,
а потім прийде доктор філософії, добре
, хлопці, зараз  ці школи зараз розташовані в
хронологічному порядку, тож давайте подивимося, що у
нас є
ігрові групи віком від трьох до
п’яти років від
трьох до п’яти, потім початкова школа
для віком від
п’яти до одинадцяти від п’яти до одинадцяти, а потім
середня школа
від одинадцяти до вісімнадцяти, але ви можете
виходь у шістнадцять,
добре, а потім о шістнадцять, я думаю, ми повинні
сісти на gc, як правильно так, вам потрібні ваші
GCES,
щоб претендувати на рівні, а також вам
потрібні gcse з
англійської мови та математики, щоб вступити до будь-якого
університету у Великобританії,
хлопці, ви уявляєте  Діти 16 років плюс
дев’ять предметів, але вони мають
лише три предмети для вивчення на рівні,
добре, і тоді ми зможемо поступити
в університет
і отримати ступінь так правильно,
добре, давайте заповнимо цю таблицю, яка
вам потрібна, щоб заповнити  друга колонка,
і
ми збираємося говорити про освіту в
україні,
добре, тому ми завершили це для
Великобританії,
а тепер, Павле, у вас є якісь
запитання
в україні,
коли я гуляю, я бачу студентів
молодше фр.  ee,
в ігрових групах так, ви цілком праві,
наші діти ходять в садок, коли їм
виповниться два роки,
звичайно, вони можуть залишатися вдома і
ходити, коли їм виповниться три
, чотири і навіть п'ять, але
деякі батьки вирішують, що їхні діти повинні
ходити до  дитячий садок, коли їм
лише два,
і вони залишаються там до шести років,
тому вони залишаються в дитячому садку до шести років, тому
вони починають
школу через рік після британських дітей
так, ми зазвичай починаємо нашу початкову школу
у віці шести років, і знову ми залишаємось
там
до 11 років, але у нас тільки
чотири класи,
так що в українській початковій школі ви
навчаєтеся в чотирьох класах, а в
британській початковій школі ви навчаєтеся
в п'яти класах,
так, у нас є перший, другий,
третій і четвертий
і  потім діти йдуть до середньої школи,
а ми маємо середню школу, тому середня
школа для дітей, які навчаються в п’ятому,
шостому,
сьомому, восьмому та дев’ятому класі, тому п’ять
класів середньої школи
і два класи середньої школи
десятого  і одинадцять, добре,
а потім у вас є оцінки з дев'яти
предметів,
і ми отримали державне підсумкове оцінювання,
і це зазвичай відбувається після дев'ятого
класу,
а діти тільки з трьох предметів.
зателефонуйте zano
no
zenyo або зовнішнє незалежне оцінювання
- це наступний рівень як
рівень для британських дітей,
а зовнішнє незалежне оцінювання -
для українських дітей, яких ви бачите, і знову
три предмети є обов'язковими, а потім
діти можуть додати ще
два предмети, якщо їм потрібно  їх за
вступ до університету добре, тому у
нас є багато спільного
між нашими двома освітніми системами,
так що різні назви, але все одно значення
полягає в одній ігровій групі та
дитячому садку,
потім початкова школа та середня, а
для нас Gcses для нас
схожі на  наша
підсумкова оцінка стану
та рівні більше схожі на наше зовнішнє
незалежне оцінювання
, ніж багато подібності,
так, добре, але є одна відмінність
чи знаєте ви, що діти у Великій Британії
мають звичку відпочивати через рік
після закінчення школи чи після
закінчення університету.
два роки добре, хлопці, чи можете ви уявити, щоб
не піти до університету відразу
після школи,
а витратити два роки на справу Пола,
роблячи все, що ви хочете, Павло, що ви зробили
добре спочатку я жив у Нью-Йорку або
поблизу Нью-Йорка,
і я викладав у спорті  свого роду
спортивний табір спортивної школи
для маленьких дітей, а по-друге, я провів
шість місяців, подорожуючи пляжами
та островами Таїланду, це було дивовижно,
шість місяців подорожей
пляжами та сторонами Таїланду
так, це просто
я навіть не уявляю, щоб все було добре
тому, хлопці, якщо ви подивитеся на цю
картинку, ви побачите різні слова
, усі вони пов’язані з перервним роком,
тому які слова привертають вашу увагу,
мої слова – це можливість навчання
та пригоди, Пол, які твої слова
мої слова - відкриття досліджувати
насолоду добре
більше веселих слів більше веселих слів добре, тому
ось такий план на рік перерви,
щоб ви могли побачити, як студент має
рюкзак
і готовий досліджувати світ,
так, і у вас тут інше
країни,
це означає, що протягом року перерви
ви можете подорожувати за кордон
і займатися добровільною роботою, можливо,
так, люди зазвичай працюють,
тому що протягом року
без грошей або два роки, як я без
грошей, вам потрібно мати певний дохід,
тому  ти все ще маєш трохи попрацювати
так, Павло, чи допомагає це дітям
бути більш готовими до їхньої освіти та
кар'єри,
я вважаю, тому деякі люди вважають, що вам
слід йти відразу до університету,
тому що ви втрачаєте звичку вчитися,
але я вірю, що ви можете отримати набагато більше
має досвід протягом усього життя,
щоб підготувати вас до життя, а не лише до
університету, тому любов – це не тільки
правильно вчитися
так добре, хлопці, як ми зрозуміли
протягом цього року перерви, ви можете отримати більше
життєвих навичок,
і ми готуємось  це для вас аудіювання,
тож, будь ласка, послухайте та
занотуйте основні моменти добре, хлопці,
тому будь ласка, будьте готові прослухати його двічі
на перерву. Колись вважалося, що рік
проводиться через те, що
щось пішло не так на шляху
від школи
до вищої освіти та
до початку кар’єри,
але тепер університети позитивно заохочують рік перерви,
і роботодавці
прихильно ставляться
до будь-якого корисного досвіду, отриманого під
час перебування поза домом,
завдяки отриманим навичкам, таким як
самостійне вирішення проблем навчання
без підтримки  Роки розриву в
самодостатності мережі та
інтернаціоналізації
зазвичай беруться перед
тим, як відправитися до університету,
але їх можна взяти в різний час,
наприклад, щоб розірвати свій диплом
або навіть перед початком навчання в аспірантурі
, вважається, що щорічно близько
100  000 британських 18-річних підлітків
відкладають початок вищої освіти таким
чином,
що становить приблизно один з восьми шкільних
важелів
e  Австралія є найпопулярнішим
місцем
для британських студентів, які
займаються стрибками з банджі та
ходять по Сіднейському мосту через гавань,
інші популярні напрямки включають Перу,
Таїланд
та Індію.
слухайте та робіть
нотатки,
якщо ви ще цього не зробили, щоб
ви побачили, що
деякі з моїх нотаток з'являться на екрані
добре, Павло, допоможіть нам ще
раз, будь ласка, так, я б хотів,
щоб рік перерви колись вважався як  взято
через те, що щось пішло
не так
на шляху від школи до
вищої освіти
та до початку вашої кар’єри,
але тепер університети позитивно заохочують рік перерви,
і роботодавці прихильно ставляться до
будь-якого корисного досвіду, отриманого під
час перебування поза домом,
тому що  здобутих навичок, таких як
незалежне вирішення проблем навчання
без підтримки мережі,
самодостатність
та інтернаціоналізм
, зазвичай витрачаються роки, перш ніж
він  на додачу до університету,
але їх можна взяти в різний час,
наприклад,
щоб припинити навчання, або навіть
перед тим, як почати навчання в аспірантурі
, вважається, що щороку близько 100
000 британських 18-річних молодих людей відкладають
початок вищої освіти в  Таким чином
, це приблизно один з восьми шкільних
важелів у Великобританії,
Австралія є найпопулярнішим
місцем для британських студентів, які
займаються такими речами, як банджі-джампінги та
прогулянки
по Сіднейському мосту Харбор-Брідж, є першими в
списку,
інші напрямки включають Перу, Таїланд
та Індію,
так що ось мої  зауважує
, наскільки я зрозумів, «у-у-у-у-у-у-року
» позитивно заохочується університетами
та роботодавцями, тому що ви отримали нові навички,
як-от розв’язування проблем самостійного навчання
без підтримки мережі,
самодостатність та інтернаціоналізм,
ви можете продовжити рік перерви не тільки після закінчення
школи,
але й  можна розірвати свій диплом
або навіть перед
проходженням аспірантури, а
на рік перерви ви можете відвідати різні  nt
країни
добре, хлопці, у вас
є завдання, ви повинні спланувати свій ідеальний
рік перерви уявіть, що наступного року
вам не потрібно ходити до школи, а
ви
збираєтеся провести рік перерви зі своїм
другом,
тож, на щастя, гроші не є  Це взагалі проблема,
і ви можете їхати, куди забажаєте, і робити
все, що забажаєте, тому зробіть
це незабутнім роком, ми хотіли б, щоб
ви працювали в парах
і планували ідеальний рік перерви, і,
звичайно,
ви можете надіслати всі свої плани нам
на нашому  електронною поштою або в Instagram,
добре, але Пол, що нам потрібно,
щоб говорити про ідеальний рік розриву,
які навички нам потрібні, щоб отримати здоров’я,
якщо учні все ще навчаються в школі, вони збираються
планувати щось, що буде в майбутньому, тому,
можливо, нам потрібно поговорити
в майбутньому  так, і щоб говорити в
майбутньому,
нам потрібен наш п'яти годинний драматичний чай, тому,
хлопці,
цього разу наші п'яті години grammati
будуть про
майбутні часи, і є три
способи виразити майбутній теперішній
безперервний
так, це поточний безперервний, але ви
будете  здатний говорити про
майбутнє, використовуючи th  є час, то
конструкція going to
і will, тож давайте подивимося,
що перша з них присутня безперервна,
а нижче ви маєте формулу суб’єкт
m is r плюс дієслово із
закінченням і решту
речення значення цього полягає в тому, коли  ви
вже вирішили
або домовилися про це, наприклад, це певний
фіксований план,
наприклад, ви купили квитки, ви
зібрали валізу, і
ви готові їхати, а потім ви кажете, що я
лечу в
Таїланд, наприклад, або в цьому
випадку ми  я отримав це речення,
Пол, чи можете ви прочитати його, будь ласка, я йду
сьогодні в кіно,
тож це означає, що у вас є квиток
правильно, ви, можливо, викликали таксі або ви
попросили своїх друзів прийти, і
все
влаштовано добре, тому ви також можете скористатися
сьогодні ввечері завтра вдень о восьмій
годині
на вихідних, що означає деякий час у майбутньому,
добре, і візьміть до відома
теперішнє просте також може мати майбутню
цінність,
особливо для розкладів, тому поїзд
відправляється о 7 00 ранку
або урок починається о 10
правильно, тому ще раз для вас  Ваші особисті
домовленості у вас є теперішній
безперервний у
вас є формула, а для
розкладів у
вас є сучасний простий, і
обидва ці часи ми використовуємо, щоб говорити
про найближче
майбутнє, яке вже влаштовано,
добре, наступне - це
будівництво  тож
формула майже така сама, але отже у вас є
підмет i ми ви вони одружуються з
Павлом Ольгою, потім приходить m is r
going to, тоді основна форма дієслова
без to і решта речення,
і ми використовуємо його для  плани та
рішення
є різниця між
організованою діяльністю
та планом, якщо у мене є план,
це означає, що я все ще не маю квитків,
я ще нікого не запросив, я все ще
планую це в своїй голові, а потім
я кажу, що  я збираюся
подивитися фільм, наприклад, це
перше використання,
друге використання— це передбачення з
доказами,
що це означає докази, докази,
коли ви,
очевидно, можете побачити щось, якщо я візьму цю
книгу,
і якщо я
зроблю це, що станеться,
це  збираюся до фа  Правильно,
це докази, це очевидно,
тому, якщо я не збережу це, він
падає так, тож давайте подивимося
на приклади
, є чорні хмари, Пол, що
станеться, буде дощ, так, ми бачимо чорні
хмари
і це  є докази, і ми кажемо, що
буде дощ
добре, тому знову ви можете використовувати наступного тижня
наступного року наступного місяця протягом одного року,
і знову, хлопці, ми говоримо про плани,
рішення та прогнози з
доказами, і останній
буде в майбутньому добре формула з  will
є дуже простим підметом буде
основа форми та решти речення,
і
ми знову використовуємо його з передбаченнями, але
без доказів немає доказів,
ви просто передбачите, що щось
станеться,
ви думаєте, ви вірите, що очікуєте, і ви
сподіваєтеся, щоб ці слова думали вірю
очікували  і надія - це свого роду лайфхаки,
якщо ви бачите фразу, я думаю,
що її слід дотримуватися
іспит я вірю в це, що
це передбачення, але без доказів
у другий раз, коли ми використовуємо його, коли ви
вирішили щось зробити
в момент виступу, наприклад,
я ношу багато важких книг,
тому Пол бачить, що я несу багато важких
книг,
і він каже  огре, я допоможу тобі
добре, тому він прийняв це рішення на
місці,
добре, тому у нас є такий приклад
, іде дощ, я візьму парасольку, тому
це беззаперечне рішення
або рішення, прийняте під час виступу,
і,
як уже сказав Пол, він сказав
я допоможу тобі він запропонував мені якусь допомогу
або він може мені щось пообіцяти
ольга я повернуся пізніше наприклад,
Павло, ти прийдеш до наступного класу
я збираюся прийти до наступного класу, це
означає, що ти запланував це
так  і ми
очікуємо, що ви зможете прийти
добре, тому ми знову зможемо використовувати
через рік наступного і одного дня,
і є невелика примітка, іноді ви
добре чуєте shell, коли я був дитиною,
мої вчителі казали мені використовувати shell, але  тепер
оболонка використовується лише для пропозицій та
запитів
наприклад, ми вип'ємо чаю
після уроку добре, так, два цукру, будь ласка,
два цукру, добре, добре,
і чи відкрию я вікно, це означає,
що я
прошу дозволу відкрити вікно добре,
хлопці,
так давайте трохи потренуємося добре, чи можу я
мати пропозицію
так, у мене є пропозиція, ось як я
це пам'ятаю, це кумедна пропозиція, я
знаю, що студенти люблять
смішні ідеї, тому давайте виберемо
приклад найкращої футбольної команди світу "
Челсі", тож я буду дивитися найкращу
футбольну команду світу "Челсі"
я йду на стадіон зі своїм другом,
і я кажу своєму другові: «
Челсі» сьогодні переможе, можливо, вони переможуть, можливо, вони не переможуть
це твій прогноз
без
доказів, а потім залишилося дві хвилини
до гри «
Челсі» виграє чотири нуля інша
команда  маю двох гравців червону картку,
тоді я кажу своєму другові, що «Челсі»
сьогодні виграє
так, тому що у вас є докази
Ніла,
двох хлопців відкидають, і
це докази, дуже гарний
приклад,
велике дякую, Пол  хлопці, нехай цей
приклад допоможе вам виконати це завдання,
подивіться на перше речення,
тож подивіться, що червона машина там
розбився, тож що б ви використали тут
, ми збираємось Пол, що ви
думаєте, е,
якщо я їду по дорозі  і я
бачу, що ця аварія ось-
ось станеться, тоді я б сказав, що їду
однозначно, тому що у вас є докази,
ви бачите це своїми очима
добре наступний не хвилюйтеся про
машину
я телефоную таксі
добре, можливо, у мене є телефон, можливо,
акумулятор
в моєму телефоні мертвий, можливо, у мене не залишилося кредиту
на моєму телефоні,
можливо, я не можу знайти свій телефон, який хочу, тому
я скористаюся will
і, звичайно, це пропозиція, як я
кажу вам, не турбуйтеся про машину,
я подзвоню  таксі або я прийняв це
рішення
на місці добре наступний я думаю,
що одного дня я буду багатим,
це те, що багато людей думають, так що
це повинно бути так, тому що у
нас є лайфхак,
подумайте, якщо ви скажете, я думаю, я сподіваюся
Я вірю, що це обов'язково буде
наступний наступний, вона вагітна, у неї
скоро буде дитина,
я вірю  напередодні є певні докази
, Ольга,
вона вагітна, вона незабаром матиме
дитину, у
нас є докази наступний,
ґе, Павло, я думаю, що хлопці можуть мати
все це як домашнє завдання
так, я думаю, що зараз всі розуміють,
особливо з моїм прикладом,
так  це було просто чудово, і тепер ви
знаєте, хлопці, що
він шанувальник Челсі, добре, хлопці, так
що
це частина вашого домашнього завдання
[Музика]
[Музика],
і дозвольте мені нагадати вам інші частини
вашого домашнього завдання, ми чекаємо вашого
плани на рік розриву
та надішліть їх на нашу електронну пошту або на
сторінки Instagram
добре ще раз, ми чекаємо на ваші
плани на ваш ідеальний рік розриву,
уважно прочитайте це завдання та сплануйте його
зі своїм
другом
[Музика]
добре, хлопці, це кінець  урок,
дякую, Пол, за підтримку та допомогу.
Ласкаво просимо, люде, побачимося наступного разу
[Музика]